the town's attempt to heal after a
tragedy
the two main high schools in Odessa
Texas have a long-running rivalry in the
football Craig states the conflict
between Permian and Odessa High has
achieved legendary status chronicled in
the book film and TV series Friday Night
Lights the teams usually bring their
community together by clashing on the
field but this year after their hometown
suffered a mass shooting that left seven
people dead the two teams are putting
the rivalry aside
Mireya Villarreal has the story before
the Odessa High School football team
took the field last night in their first
game since last weekend's mass shooting
we honored the community paid tribute to
those who were lost one week ago a
gunman opened fire from a moving vehicle
killing seven people and injuring at
least 25 others across Midland County
and Odessa the shooter was killed by
police outside a movie theater less than
a month ago there was a shooting in El
Paso
well I'm heartbroken by the crying of
the people instead of Texas I'm tired of
the dying for the people instead of
Texas among those killed 15 year-old
Lela Adnan this it was a normal Saturday
and I see all over the media prayers to
Leyland I hate how she didn't get to
make it
and it's just hard for everybody who was
close to her ed none this was an Odessa
High School student and played on the
basketball team a few months ago she
celebrated her quinceanera yesterday was
her funeral Bryce McKinney is friends
with Layla's older brother Nathan who
was also shot but survived yet called me
and it was probably the most emotional
conversation I've ever had like I don't
I don't cry a lot but I couldn't keep it
together you could just like hear you
could hear it in his voice he was just
heartbroken I can only imagine hearing
that pain created the motivation for
Bryce to bring students together from
the rival schools to help victims their
families and the community heal what is
it about the rivalry then that will kind
of like flow into this it weaves into
this as well I think there is no more
rivalry right now everybody's together
like there's there is no rivalry
everybody is coming together for
something that happened and not worried
about the rivalry for CBS this morning
Saturday media vol Odessa Texas amazing
to hear him say that right now there is
no rivalry we're together and sports is
such a unifier I mean you think about it
their towns have divides between them
but when it comes to that game day
they're all in it together we all know
what that feeling is like you just join
the same team on that day